Joey is in the Ramsey baby-steps
community if you didn't know on Facebook
we have the official the Ramsey capital
t-h-e
Ramsey baby-steps community about
$100,000 Dave just getting started on
the plan super motivated even though my
wife just will not get on board
she will not combine our money it feels
like she would be paying off my debts
since it's my student loans we don't
have a lot of debt but with her income
we could pay off the debt and mortgage
and basically half the time what do I do
to convince her you have a marriage
problem you don't have a money problem
and you need to sit down with your
pastor or with a good marriage counselor
because your wife missed the part in the
marriage vows for richer for poorer in
sickness and health she's not your
freaking roommate your roommate
shouldn't have to pay your bills your
wife should she gets sick and has to go
for cancer treatments guess what you're
gonna be holding her head while she's
throwing up in the toilet that's how
life works when you're married you take
care of each other this is what marriage
is about submit yourselves one to
another in sickness and in health for
richer for poorer unto thee all my
worldly goods I pledge is the old
marriage vows you don't hear those used
anymore they're not quite hip enough for
some people but that's how you properly
live my wife has not had an income in 34
years but she has a really good income
because there's not a she and me there's
a we we have a really good household
income and thus Sharon has a really good
household income but she has not earned
an income as an individual in the
marketplace
since our oldest child was born
does that mean that she shouldn't have a
say or that we shouldn't share no unique
marriage counseling Joey
bad bad your wife thinks she's your
roommate and we need to work on that I
hope that helps
[Music]